I know that I am not particularly predisposed towards metaphysical questions
because I don't think they can really be answered.
So the idea of what started the universe, uh,
we can't really answer that. I think that to say, God,
that's just a placeholder for ignorance that doesn't help.
I may have to get you in here with Prager to discuss it. Yeah. Yeah.
So where did God come from? It just,
it's just putting off that moment of ignorance a little bit further.
Hey,
I'm Dave Rubin and unless I've been impeached by a completely partisan vote,
this is still the Rubin report, uh,
as always a quick reminder to click the subscribe bell.
So you guys have a small chance of seeing our videos right here on the YouTube.
And more importantly,
joining me today is an author political commentator and fellow at the Manhattan
Institute. Heather McDonald. Welcome back to the Rubin report. It's.
Such an honor, Dave, thank you so much for having me on.
I'm glad to have you back had you on about a year ago and uh,
the people they love you. That's what I learned.
That's what I learned in the YouTube comments, sections.
Being in your presence. You know, it's,
there's so much love coming at you that they're a little spilled.
All right, well then you're killing it in the scarf game today.
So I feel like I have to be very sharp. Brilliant. So here we go.
So one of the things I wanted to start with here is something that we discussed
briefly about five or 10 minutes in our last interview.
You are a secular conservative.
And I think a lot of conservatives seem to think that that is an,
either an oxymoron or just simply cannot exist because conservatism
has to have some sort of religious underpinnings.
So I thought that would just be an interesting place for us to pick up the
conversation.
I based my conservatism on, on empirical truth,
on what I've observed in life. Uh,
I can talk about the necessity of the two parent family,
because we can see empirically what happens when the marriage norm breaks down
in communities. Uh,
I support most traditional values because I think we have a history
of, of stability when those are honored.
I don't think it's particularly stable to rest a set of political
principles or moral principles on the basis of revealed
wisdom that this Holy book supports this. And I've,
I'll notice this people who I respect enormously, Dave,
whether it's Dennis Prager or Michael Medved that are making the
argument that you cannot have a moral society without
a foundation of religious belief, I would ask them,
these are two brilliant Jewish thinkers.
Why don't you believe that Jesus is the son of God.
It's revealed truth.
The new Testament says that this is gospel.
They don't believe that.
Especially if you're going that far with religion. And you're saying,
you need this reveal of truth, this belief to organize a society.
Why not the next level of the reveal of truth or whatever the next level is or
something like.
Right?
They will not take it as simply necessary
truth. The fact that the new Testament claims to be the word of God,
why don't they believe that they're basing their same belief in the old
Testament on the same claim that the new Testament makes they just choose to be
agnostic or atheist about one of those Holy books,
I could apply the same challenge to their belief that the old
Testament is the revealed truth, because it's simply a self,
uh self-validating.
So I would look for a different set of principles that are,
does not depend on one's suspension of disbelief and an
acceptance that something is revealed truth for my moral code.
So with that being said,
does it matter to you if the end result is the same? Right?
So I'm going to guess that on most of the important issues of the day,
you probably agree in large part with both Dennis and Michael Medved
and most conservative thinkers that maybe come from a more religious background.
So at the end of the day, when it all washes away, do you,
do you think it really matters? Do you think that's sort of a long-term problem?
I know, I guess if we arrived at the same place, I think it's,
it it's a problem for that segment of voters or,
or thinkers who don't find those appeals particularly interesting,
but I have to, I'll be very honest, Dave,
part of my resistance to this is simply
I don't find claims of petitionary prayer and the idea of a
personal, loving God consistent with what I see,
what I call the daily massacre of the innocence. To me,
it's a very hard claim to make that I should expect God to pay
attention to my wellbeing when he's willing to allow horrific things
to happen to people far more deserving and innocent than I am. So for me,
it's partly just a truth value.
I cannot stomach what appears to me to be a patently
false claim about a personal loving God.
It's interesting. I've mentioned that I've had, uh,
John Casick in here who is the former governor of Ohio and a presidential
candidate, obviously. And when I asked him about faith,
he said something that I, that sounded sort of, um, almost flipping, uh,
but I thought it was really actually pretty insightful. He said, you know,
some people can do it with God. I just can't.
And I thought that was actually like, you know, for a certain set of people,
they,
where you're able to sort of always sort of maybe go back to your intellectual
side. Some people just sort of get tired of that does that.
Well, I, and I also think it's a very, I think it's genetic.
I know that I am not particularly predisposed towards metaphysical questions
because I don't think they can really be answered.
So the idea of what started the universe, uh,
we can't really answer that. I think that to say, God,
that's just a placeholder for ignorance, right. That doesn't help.
You know? Cause he may have to get you in here with Prager regress. Yeah.
Oh, so where did God come from? It just,
it's just putting off that moment of ignorance a little bit further.
So I don't find those questions particularly relevant. On the other hand,
I recognize that for much of humanity,
that is a very deep need to ask these basic
questions about origin and an end point where we all headed.
What is the meaning of life to me, anybody who claims that they don't,
he doesn't find meaning in life when there is Mozart and heightened to
invoke a Dennis Prager favorite or Beethoven or John Milton or
escalas, or, or, or, or Anthony, Trollope.
Just waking up with purpose for whatever you do doing.
To do the best you can do. I don't find life meaningless for one second.
Yeah. So does it worry you then.
In Republicans or more broadly conservatives talk about God all the time or now
that we're seeing sort of a huge fracture in what's happening with the left,
they're like completely afraid to even mention God or anything like that.
Bernie, I think is basically an atheist,
although he won't really say it cause I think there would be political
repercussions. Um, but are you like,
does that make you sort of feel not totally at home with the conservatives?
Well, you know, I,
I grew up in a very secular environment and so it was a novel
discovery to me in the nineties when I was in a more conservative writing
circle. And I grew up as a default liberal, uh,
I hadn't been exposed to religion. I mean, it is an amazing thing.
I had been educated on the coasts and I didn't realize
how different they were. So in one sense, I'm very parochial.
Uh, and I hadn't been exposed to the degree of religious faith. Uh,
I guess I find it.
I I'm always amazed what to me seems parochialism when I hear specially
Christians in a political environment,
getting up there and talking about Jesus has God. My view immediately is, well,
there are Jews around, you know, at the village and there are Muslims.
How can you be so confident that everybody in this audience is of
that particular faith? Uh,
and I also would notice simply that religion has been
tamed by the enlightenment.
It is now been taught to mind its manners and sit quietly in the corner.
We all, you know, the, the,
the great kissy WiSci between Jews and Christians that we all now talk about the
Judeo-Christian environment, uh, heritage, heritage,
and perhaps rightly so that's.
Right. It wasn't like that.
There were things called the crusades at all by brothers though. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. And all these religious supporters.
You're saying we cannot live without it.
They are conveniently overlooking what the history of religion has been
in our tradition and still is in many other places that have not
gone through the enlightenment.
The concept of tolerance is not a religious concept.
It's an enlightenment concept and religion in the
West has been forced to accept tolerance,
which is a very good thing,
but that is not an idea that is inherent to religion. Right.
So I don't want to be Prager or [inaudible] at the moment.
But I think what they would say is that it was the,
it was all the religious stuff that organized society that allowed us to get to
the enlightenment so that the enlightenment could then, you know,
unfurl all these good ideas.
Well, I don't think, I don't think Christianity or Judaism,
Christianity has any necessary monopoly on moral virtues.
I think there's a certain core sense of,
I don't know any culture that says murder is okay,
but every culture starts to make certain distinctions what they don't last that
long, but it's fun for a moment, you know, you get to give it into your,
your most, uh, aggressive tendencies. Right?
Where do you think, um, Trump falls out on this?
Cause I don't think anyone really thinks he's a religious person or perhaps even
a believer in any real sense of it yet Christians or evangelicals,
especially really seem to like the job that he's doing.
Well, I don't think he has particular principles or deep thoughts about much of
anything. I think he will. He's a chameleon.
He takes on the coloring of what is convenient at the time.
So whether he believes or not, I, I, I, I don't know. He,
I don't think he's thought much deeply about it either. Uh,
and it doesn't really matter, but certainly he's willing to speak that rhetoric,
uh, in order to get, get that vote.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.